Oh sno-cone yes hyperactive little
reindeer my name is Noel Kringle morning
princess my partridge in a pear tree
underwear needs washing
oh well then my Christmas wish has been
granted Christmas runs in my family my
dad was Santa and now it's my brother
next turn to wear the hat stocking full
of coal feathers see one he saved a
kitten from a tree nice well your
brother would be ready by Christmas of
course sometimes I dream about getting
out well you can't be Santa if you're
having a nervous breakdown
you took it away for the weekend the
first time in 2,000 years
Santa has disappeared I just said he
should take the weekend off we must have
a new set of Gabriel Kringle me I'm in
the tech department and loving it
what about a rescue mission do you mind
telling me what you're doing I'm going
to get my brother and you're coming with
me
stay right where you are we are looking
for Santa Claus
you don't tell anybody who you are where
are you think I'll go to town up north
poor or you came from sir it's a
privilege to wear that suit put some
pants on
so knobby Christmas Eve is less than 48
hours away this could be the perfect
time to start an online delivery
platform we've gotta find Santa
thousands of years we have jingle bells
and delivered toys and we must make sure
nothing changes that
[Music]
I like your pants they're jolly their
yoga pants like yours these are my
yogurt pants and no yoga pants and love
yogurt pants don't want facing reindeer
please wow that's a big deal in here
you